la tabla abajo nos muestra el número de
pollos vendidos por cuatro amigos desde
enero hasta marzo excepto una de las
entradas que está faltando qué número
debería de ir en la celda vacía y de
hecho aquí tenemos los nombres de omán
nadia gabriela y emily y cuánto ha
venido cada uno desde enero hasta marzo
y el total a nosotros nos están
preguntando cuál es el número que va en
la celda vacía en este caso tenemos una
celda vacía aquí
el total de gabriela
nosotros no tenemos este dato como tal
pero sí podemos obtenerlo y es muy
sencillo dado que sabemos cuántos vendió
en enero cuantos vendió en febrero y
cuántos vendió en marzo de tal manera
que el total de pollos vendidos por
gabriela será la suma de enero + febrero
+ marzo en este caso enero fue 1 febrero
fueron 0 y en marzo también solo vendió
1 por lo que tiene uno más 12 vamos a
colocar como respuesta
dos pollos y comprobemos nuestra
respuesta
es correcta hagamos uno más
en la tabla de abajo se muestra cuántas
instalaciones de paneles solares por
estado se han hecho en el último año
fiscal excepto una entrada que está
faltando y una vez más tenemos aquí los
datos de varios estados de eeuu de
norteamérica y en cada cuarto cuánto se
vendió podemos ver entonces que aquí nos
falta este dato tenemos esta celda vacía
y nosotros no sabemos cuánto vendió
alabama en el cuarto cuarto sin embargo
si tenemos el total y las ventas del
primero segundo y tercer cuarto de tal
manera que si nosotros sumamos el cuarto
uno dos tres y cuatro nos debería de
sumar 132 paneles solares para que
nosotros podamos saber cuántos fueron en
el cuarto cuarto pues a 132 le resta
haremos las ventas del primero segundo y
tercer cuarto a 132
arrestaremos 39 menos 40 menos 33 y esto
será igual a una venta de 20 paneles
durante el cuarto cuarto vamos a colocar
nuestra respuesta otra forma en la que
podemos pensarlo es por una suma si
nosotros tenemos 39 más 40 más 33
tendremos una suma total de 112 paneles
solares y si a eso nosotros le sumamos
20 en el cuarto cuarto pues tendremos el
gran total de 132 que es justo lo que
nos muestra aquí la tabla
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta
y es correcta vamos a hacer ahora más
mismo caso nos están dando los paneles
solares por estado y por cada uno de los
períodos fiscales del año vamos a ver
que en este caso en nueva york nos está
faltando el tercer cuarto vamos a hacer
lo mismo que hicimos en el ejercicio
pasado sumaremos 40 más 34 son 74
y esos 74 le sumaremos los 25 del último
cuarto del año con eso tendremos 99
paneles si durante todo el año vendimos
122 paneles pues a 122 le resta haremos
la suma que acabamos de hacer de 99
paneles y con ello tendremos 23 paneles
vamos a comprobar que la suma de 40 34
más 23 más 25 será igual a 122
comprobemos nuestra respuesta es
correcta hagamos uno más
en este caso nos indican que la tabla
nos da los puntos que cuatro jugadores
han hecho en un partido de basquetbol
una vez más tenemos una de las celdas
vacías y en este caso nos preguntan
cuáles fueron los puntos finales de
emily pues eso está muy fácil porque si
nosotros sumamos el total de puntos que
ha realizado en cada uno de los cuartos
del juego podremos saber el final
tenemos 2 más 10 12 + 10 22 más 6 28
vamos a poner 28 como nuestra respuesta
final y la comprobaremos
y es correcta